لا يعبرون النهر انما شوارع مدينتهم خرسون
الغارقه بالمياه بعد تفجير سد كخوفكا
ومحطته الكهرومائيه الواقعه على نهر
دينيبرو بين ضفتيه هذه الزوارق فقط باتت
الوسيله الوحيده للتحرك بعدما ارتفع مستوى
المياه الى اكثر من اربعه امتار وغمرت
الاف المنازل تطوع اندريه وصديقه كالمئات
غيرهم للبحث عن ناجين رغم كونهما ايضا من
المتضررين
حتى اللحظه اكثر من 30 شخصا بقارب الصغير
هذا انه وضع غير معقول انها كارثه الالاف
تم اجلائهم لكن البحث عن المزيد متواصل
نساء
تحاول فرق الانقاذ اجلاء المزيد من السكان
لقد غامرت المياه 29 بلده بشكل كامل في
خرسون عشر منها في الاراضي المحتله مؤقته
حجم الكارثه طال كل كائن حي في هذه
المدينه في احلك الظروف يصل هؤلاء الى بر
غير امن تماما فالحدث الذي وصفته الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باكبر كارثه انسانيه من صنع
البشر منذ عقود ليس طبيعيا بل نتيجه تفجير
متعمد تتهم اوكرانيا روسيا بتنفيذه لتعطيل
عمليات استعاده الضفه اليسرى من النهر
بينما ينفي الروس هذه الروايه ومن هناك
وصل بعدما وحدت الكارثه حال الضفتين
المتقاتلتين
خلال هذين اليومين لم نرى لها مثيلا اتيت
عبر النهر ورايت جنود الروسي يفرلون من
مواقعهم ووصلت الى هنا مع عائلتي بعد عناء
وسط مخاطره كبيره اجدي اكثر من 1500 شخص
من 80 بلده غارقه في اليوم الاول فقط على
التفجير عبر مياه تحركت داخلها الالغام
التي كانت مزروعه على طول جبهه النهر ما
شكل حاله معقده بات السكان اكبر ضحاياها
لطالما قال الاوكرانيون انه منتظروا طويلا
كي تجف هذه الارض فيبدا هجومهم المضاد لكن
تفجير السد اغرقها هذه المره قد يكون
الماء اطفئ نار الجبهه هنا مؤقتا لكن
رياحها قد تهب في جبهه اخرى مستغله هذا
الظرف او قد تشتعل هنا مجددا بعد انحسارها
انما بواقع ميداني مختلف حسم مسعود
الجزيره